- But you'll appreciate this.
That's what people said about Snoop.
Dre put you on.
The Chronic was the biggest album ever.
Until Snoop proved that he was an artist.
You know what I mean?
That's just the truth.
Like, that's what's so great about it.
Like, that was the point.
Which is like
The market.
Your skills.
Like, what you got in
you is gonna play out.
(discordant music
(men yelling)
- [Gary Vaynerchuk] You've
got your perspective.
(audience roars)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- This DailyVee?
- [Caleb] it is DailyVee.
- (unintelligible) D Kirk.
My man Gary is spittin' some
major knowledge for you guys.
Make sure you smarten up,
and pay attention.
Maybe take some notes or whatnot.
Real entrepreneurship life.
Peace.
- [Caleb] Damn.
Just walks right in
and is already on fire.
- (unintelligible) already.
- [Caleb] What the hell.
- Sheesh.
- [Caleb] Alright, here he comes.
♪ Da da dum da da dum da da dum dum dum. ♪
- (speaks off mic)
(speaks off mic)
- [Caleb] You can just throw
the mic on. (unintelligible)
- (speaks off mic)
- Andy.
(needle scratch, crickets chirping)
Who's that?
Yeah, we're gonna find out.
(bass-heavy beats)
I met this young man in, at USC
when I was there the other day.
(needle scratch)
- Thank you, bro, thank you.
And he showed me this.
You should sit down and look at it.
- [Team member 1] I think I've seen
- [blue shirt man] Yeah, you would.
- How?
- [Team member 1] (speaks off mic)
- [blue shirt] I sent
it in, like, January.
- (laughs) Amazing.
I'm now completely convinced
this is a super important project.
That he nailed it.
You need to really look at it.
- [Team member 1] (speaks off mic)
Please, talk.
- [Team member 1] When I first saw this,
I, because we get we
get sent all this stuff
all the time in office,
I spent like one minute.
And I was like, this actually seems like
this dude knows what he's
doing with the project.
- I, we, I need like two
or three eyes on this.
but yours the most.
If it's as good as I think it is,
I think I want to
turn it into an actual
(beep)
- You know about when you first started.
For an artist when he first
starts creating music.
That he has all these fresh-ass ideas.
Like, his first real
creativity, real pain.
Real, like, emotion.
Fresh music.
So I have that section of music
in that period of my life.
And right now I went back.
With all my resources, just tuned them up.
Remixed the master.
Got everything ready.
- Right, cause those stories
are the purest.
- Yeah.
(discordant hip-hop)
♪ Ayo Lil Mexico, pass the gas ♪
♪ Yeah (whoops) ♪
♪ She wanna link ♪
♪ I got a freezer my link ♪
♪ Blueberry diamonds my teeth ♪
♪ You know my diamonds they sink ♪
♪ My diamonds sink ♪
- Whether a person who starts their career
drops a project with no features because
they want to establish themselves,
or they start a project with six features
because they were part of a crew
and they got great relationships and
they got hot people on it,
at the end of the day, 10 years later,
either you've got skills, or you do not.
Like, you know, it's like sports.
There's a score.
Like, you how many people
thought Drake sucked?
At the end of day, you can say it.
But the market speaks.
- The market speaks for itself.
- Not X-X-L not One 37 PM.
Not Mike Boyd, not you, not me.
The market.
- The market.
- (distorted droning)
- (slowed vocal) The market.
You know.
And like, some people are good enough
to have one project that's decent.
Some people play forever.
(unintelligible)
Some artists take different routes.
You know, some artists
like to just to work
with, like, five different artists.
And just get that, (whistles)
that pull that they need.
(unintelligible)
You get that momentum up there.
Everyone's gonna have to
say, oh, that you're up there
because (unintelligible) put you on.
So for the rest if your career,
oh yeah, he got --
- But you'll appreciate this.
That's what people said about Snoop.
Dre put you on.
The Chronic was the biggest album ever.
Until Snoop proved that he was an artist.
You know what I mean?
That's just the truth.
Like, that's what's so great about it.
Like, that was the point.
Which is like...
the market.
Your skills.
Like, what you got in
you is gonna play out.
Just like you for your
brand, just like me.
That's the beauty of the game.
That's why it's only about the customer.
That's why the biggest mistake
everyone's making right now,
is they are nobody.
They fuck with fans heavy.
D-M them back, make videos.
Cause you're hungry.
You're hungry.
You want to win.
You want to get put on.
Every fan matters.
You can't believe somebody gave a fuck.
Oh shit, this is what
I was always thinking.
You care, you care, you care.
And then you pop.
And you get fancy.
- So it's getting into their head.
It starts changing people.
- It gets really hard to be hungry
when you've got a lot of food.
- (speaks off mic)
- You want copy on this 2012 one?
We're letting the last one
breathe after the 400-K.
(cheery music)
- [Young Gary On phone
video] (unintelligible)
Mainly because I've
caught up with my email.
- Yeah, I want copy.
Did it just go up, or
is it about to go up?
- Yeah, you can have it right now.
- I'll give it to you right now.
- Cool.
- I'm gonna text you personally.
- [Young Gary On Video] (unintelligible)
- (dictating) Back in 2012
I wasn't really making content
- [John] First video I saw.
- What did you say?
- [John] It was the first video I saw.
- Look what I wrote.
Opening line.
- Wow.
- [John] (speaks of mic)
- Literally, I wrote.
That was such an incredible moment.
- Look how many goosebumps.
You got that, Caleb, right?
Literally what I wrote,
"I know for many of you
this was the first video you saw of me."
- That's right.
- [Caleb] (laughs) What's it say?
- (dictates) Back in 2012
I wasn't really making content
but got inspired...
to shoot...
it super fucking straight.
(speaks normally) That's what it was.
I remember that video
like fucking yesterday.
I did it on my computer.
I was doing email to London.
- [Young Gary] I'm so
desperate to figure out how to
convince people that there
is no loss in going for it.
That and the airplane project.
I hope it happens again.
- [Caleb] So real --
- Of course it will.
- Please don't look at the screen.
It's very confidential.
(chuckles)
(number pad tones)
- [Interviewer on phone] Hello.
- Hey, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
How are you?
- [Interviewer] Good, how are you?
This is (unintelligible)
How's it going?
- It's going extremely well.
I first probably heard about the company
maybe six months ago.
Well actually, first
heard about the company
maybe even a year,
maybe fifteen, sixteen,
seventeen months ago.
- [Announcer] Liquid I-V,
a healthy, all-natural
re-hydration beverage
that promotes rapid recovery.
Kind of hit my radar as I was
paying attention to what
was happening on Amazon
with brands that were not, let's say,
from the Fortune 500 landscape.
Kind of just hit my radar.
Like, oh that brand is doing quite well
in organic search and
things of that nature.
Then I had the luxury of meeting Brandon.
And.
What.
That was maybe six months ago.
The reason I decided to invest was,
I've become completely passionate about
investing in the
entrepreneur over everything
if she or he capture my attention.
(intense sci-fi sound effect)
And I believe in them.
I want to bet more on the
jockey, less on the horse.
And so,
it was very, very, very, very, very clear
to me that Brandon was, and is
going to be a successful
operator and entrepreneur.
And that's really it.
It's not super complicated.
It was that binary.
- [Young Gary on video] When
I talk about transparency,
like, you're going to be exposed, people.
I know people are watching right now.
I get the space, (unintelligible)
The fiddler, the Twitter.
- The fiddler.
- [Young Gary] You're
gonna get exposed, right?
And so, like, if you're
always responding to
Gary Vaynerchuk or Kevin Rose or iJustine,
but not to Sally Pants McGee,
- Sally Pants!
- [Young Gary] For me, that fact that
you've got this secret thing going on,
and I was able to kind of pass that test.
That shit's forever.
You know it's real.
And that's awesome.
And to me, that's why I
keep talking about it.
Everything's gonna be exposed.
There's way too many patent
ways to flip the switch,
or to catch somebody
off-guard, or flip cams,
or live from your cellphone.
You don't think that a
couple iPhones from now
we're gonna be direct to
internet, live to the internet?
It is --
- Holy shit!
(riotous crowd )
- [Young Gary] You know we've
got (unintelligible) already.
- [Team member 2] (speaks off mic)
- [Young Gary] To catch
somebody off guard,
or flip cams, or live from your cellphone.
You don't think that a
couple iPhones from now
we are gonna be direct to
internet, live to the internet?
(unintelligible)
You know, we've got
those things out already.
They're gonna be mainstream.
And so.
It's just,
You know what, good is
gonna win this game.
You know, technology is going to
allow good to win because you can't hide.
- [D-Rock] I tell people
that all the time.
Don't lie, because the internet
will make you seem like a --
- [Young Gary] Some of you just lie.
It happens --
- [D-Rock] Making a mistake,
that's something different.
But being --
- [Team member 2] Yeah.
- Couple observations.
First, I need to bring wristbands back.
- [Young Gary] What do
I want to do every day
for the rest of my life?
Do that. (bell dings)
- Second, Sally's been around
for a long fucking time.
- [Young Gary] You know,
Sally Arkansas that's
eating Doritos and watching a commercial?
(sentimental music)
- Third, I just fucking understand
human behavior mixed with technology.
I hope you enjoyed this clip,
and I hope you understand how
evergreen the points of views,
the manifestos, the hypothesis-es
is that I roll with, are.
You know, all this shit has
been written a long time ago.
The only thing you have
to overlay is technology.
I know what you're gonna do.
(laughs)
- [Caleb] What are you doing right now?
- I just watched a clip from D-Rock.
Now I'm filming the
add-on, the split screens.
These recalls we think are some of
the best content we're putting out.
Because they're fun.
I personally like being right.
And more importantly I think
they're adding value to people.
That they now are starting to understand
this is not a byproduct of, like,
what I'm talking about now
that I have eyes on me.
I've been talking about that.
And in that consistency,
and then understanding
what that consistency meant to
the results that I'm getting,
can inspire so many of you to
double down on these human
truths that I will be
absolutely pontificating
about in perpetuity.
(Choppy music)
♪ (crooning) ♪
♪ (unintelligible) ♪